Ashton and company's hip, comfort food joint is next on Grubber's Delight.
Hey there, food lovers! I'm Catherine Cronenberg and you're watching Grubber's Delight,...
...the best show on the Internet for anybody who loves to eat.
We've been taking a look at the best celeb-owned eateries around LA,...
...and Ketchup in West Hollywood offers comfort food from the stars.
"That '70s Show" stars Ashton Kutcher, Wilmer Valderrama, and Danny Masterson...
...are among the investors in Ketchup,...
...and its sister restaurants, Dolce and the Geisha House,...
...that make it the hippest place to get meat loaf in the city.
Ketchup mixes comfort food styles with a hip, upscale vibe,...
...offering a menu of burgers, ribs, sloppy joes, battered chicken, and yes, meatloaf...
...that will remind you of home while surprising you with their gourmet tastes.
The restaurant takes its name...
...from the fact that their menu features five different flavors of ketchup,...
...and the place's white tables and booths are bathed in a red glow...
...to add to the tomato theming.
And even though the prices at Ketchup are a bit pricey for burgers and meat loaf,...
...you can save lots of money by going to the restaurant on Sundays,...
...when everything is half off.
Just be warned, if you do go on Sundays, you'll miss bartender...
...who wheels a cart of free, mini martinis around the restaurant...
...every other night of the week.
So, you're left with a choice of saving money on food...
...or getting free specialty martinis approved by the stars of "That '70s Show".
There are so many tough choices for LA citizens to make.
I'm Catherine Cronenberg for Grubber's Delight, reminding you to eat well.